e os melhores sustos e reações 81
[Música]
oi oi
facultar muito já corta menos
no meu ouvido tá
e
aquelas pouquinho tá
[Música]
eu bonito para caramba não é o mestre
Então nesse
a nossa primeira é
[Música]
Oi
Pedro
tudo para mim
é uma coisa que mexer filha da [ __ ] tem
que tá aqui mamãe está trabalhando já é
uma coisa vocês viram ó
é
[ __ ] se
vou poder uma luz um
oi oi o bicho pode ser uma vez pode ser
ai [ __ ] foge para cá
[Música]
e
quando for gosta mais rápido o porto
abriu ainda agora comecei já começa com
coisas paranormais acontecer no canal
ainda não precisa só Conrado se joga
vou deixar abrir e não vou olhar
em volta para
fazer ai ai eu tô confuso
rápido e
[Música]
E aí
A
culpa não é o Tá muito barulho não sai
fora o
o Marco a
corrupção
[Música]
como é que eu estava bem longe e
a
[Aplausos]
sua burra porque ela não está a ver
ainda mesmo que ela me veja todas o
corrupção público
e eu já te dou gerador agora tem que ir
lá para cima outra vez né ah
o ramo [ __ ] é possível passar isto é
quem vai presidir Claro não sei que mais
depois espera aí aparece cara
não era para ser assim
aí agora sai vai sair muito cedo não
eu saí muito cedo
só fosse ai apanharam filhos da mãe e
E
ai ouviu o meu cu o meu cuzinho está
sangrar nesse momento não
apaga a luz já não estou gostar disso já
jantou mandar para o
nível 6 Presidente essa merda ciência e
ciência e
e
já não assusta estou preparado já estou
pronto para isso
E
[Música]
aí agora não vai crescer outra vez tá
OK Tá tudo bem Tá tudo tranquilo [ __ ]
a
[Música]
Bengala Bengala
agora parece que não
o significado É este aqui Eu nem liguei
a TV o que é estragada
João Oi Fred Robocop meu Deus
mais um cortinho
demônio demônio
pessoal eu
não sei onde é que é
e o traiu Olha aí um seita na
Ai meu Deus está com muito susto
Ok eu vou dar o piloto mais tarde porque
eu ainda tenho que vida é isso não não
[Música]
todas por aí por aí por aí
po po po po
tem muito estranho não parece um
[Música]
oi
oi oi você não consigo andar
vamos lá
E ai
não
coloca velho do mundo morre a cada vez
que os meus pais não estavam em casa
acho que é um
[Música]
sonho habbzone Botafogo
[ __ ]
edições filha da [ __ ] hein
[Música]
e
por qualquer coisa abriu aqui
[Música]
agora é só esperar o dinheiro aí
e eu faço explodidos